hallo leute willkommen zu einer neuen
episode unserer super easy german reihe
in welcher wir euch jede woche ein neues
deutsches werk vorstellen
diese woche geht es um das verb geben
wir zeigen euch wie es konjugiert und in
verschiedenen zeit form verwenden könnt
los gehts präsens ich gebe
du gibst er sie es gibt wir geben ihr
gebt sie geben wer gibt wem was jemandem
etwas geben so viel gibt dem mann eine
flasche wasser
ich gebe dir eine flasche wasser
sophie hat mir eine flasche wasser
gegeben
ich gebe euch eine chance wir geben euch
ein geschenk den weihnachtsmann gibt es
wirklich ihr gebt euch mühe beim deutsch
lernen
du gibst uns viel freude
sie geben uns viel inspiration
was gibt es auf dem hof es gibt einen
strandkorb
es gibt eine hängematte es gibt eine
bank
es gibt zwei tischtennisplatten
es gibt einen basketballkorb präteritum
ich glaub du gabst er sie es gab
wir gaben ihr gehabt sie gaben kari hat
lecker gekocht echt was gab es gab
nudelauflauf mit salat lecker richard
gab mir einen roten stift
wir gaben uns den ellenbogen zur
begrüßung perfekt ich habe gegeben
du hast gegeben er sie es hat gegeben
wir haben gegeben ihr habt gegeben
sie haben gegeben alina hat sowie eine
kopfnuss gegeben
ich habe richard einen heiß gegeben
ihr habt euer bestes gegeben sie haben
uns eine antwort gegeben
wir haben uns mühe gegeben
du hast mir eine giftige pflanze gegeben
futur ich werde geben
du wirst geben er sie es wird geben wir
werden geben
ihr werdet geben sie werden geben
ich möchte mehr lesen
ich werde dir mein lieblingsbuch zu
lesen geben löst du mir bescheid geben
ja klar sophie er wird mir einen korb
geben bestimmt wir werden euch mehr
aufgaben geben
sie werden uns nichts geben ich glaube
auch dass wir uns nichts geben werden
ihr werdet dafür alles geben müssen
gleich werden wir euch zwei formen des
konjunktivs 2 des verbs geben vorstellen
alle deutschen werben besitzen diese
zwei formen aber nicht bei allen werden
werden auch beide formen in der
gesprochenen sprache verwendet beim der
abgeben werden beide formen verwendet
und es ist auch abhängig vom kontext
welche form natürlich erklingt
konjunktiv 2 ich gebe du gibst er sie es
gebe wir geben ihr gebt sie geben so
viel ich will reich werden
es gebe da eine möglichkeit
was gäbe ich dafür größer zu sein
konjunktiv 2 ich würde geben
du würdest geben er sie es würde geben
wir würden gäben ihr würdet geben
sie würden geben sophie würdest du mir
deine kopfhörer geben
natürlich gebe ich dir meine kopfhörer
danke ich glaube ich würde mir gerne den
job geben
sie würden uns dafür kein geld geben
das war unser super easy german video zu
dem verb geben wenn ihr jetzt euer
deutsch noch weiter verbessern möchte
dann empfehlen wir euch unsere app sieht
lang auszuprobieren
dort haben wir unter anderem ein
aussprache trainer mit dem ihr eure
aussprache trainieren könnte indem ihr
sie mit der eines muttersprachler
vergleicht so könnt ihr eure deutsche
aussprache schritt für schritt
verbessern
viel spaß dabei und bis bald
[Musik]